welcome to the across this bowl of us
podcast I'm your host Paul joined by the
birthday boy Greg Alba happy birthday to
you happy birthday to you you gave me a
big speech on my birthday I've not
prepared one for you but I will say
how dare you Greg said look Greg is a
lovely lovely man
um he's a he's someone I speak to every
day you've been so supportive over the
last two two or three years uh when we
first met I was having a bit of a
meltdown going through a crazy crisis
behind the scenes on Youtube and Greg
was there just calm everything down and
talk me through it and we got we got
here in the end
um and yeah I kind of met there's there
wouldn't be a better person to have just
listened to my every day and being
so supportive and I really appreciate
everything that you've done Greg you're
an amazing human
um you're one of the game changers in
YouTube as well if you if you look at
reactions I guarantee they've stolen
something that Greg's done and put it on
their Channel well look will not stay
stolen you will say you've influenced
them to do something
um and yeah you've been you've been just
a great guy in front of the camera
behind the camera and yeah happy
birthday how many years around the sun
has it been uh 30 33 thank you for the
thank you for the words man it was a you
know I had a weird weekend with uh
I'm going to give a heads up here I I
had to go to the I had to go to urgent
care and then I just spent my and I just
decided to relax for my birthday
Paul has a bunch of stories here
so it's going to be that for all those
who already like clown on me in the
comment boxes I'm gonna give you more
ammo today because it's the least
prepared I've ever been for a podcast
today and um so it's gonna be a lot of
me nodding and listening to Paul and me
going all right man let me work on the
thumbnail and create some stupid
chapters so that's what it's going to be
today we're going to have a fun time and
I really appreciate that man I want to
talk about what the hell happened with
you because you said you'd be an ill all
day and I was like just take a resume
just take a rest you're like oh no but
I've got to get these videos done I was
like no it sounds like you're quite ill
you you always get in trouble when you
really push yourself and you know I just
I'll I'll do it I'll do it and I I said
just rest I'm going to bed we're in
different time zones I'm going to bed
and then I woke up to see you a photo of
you laid out on a hospital bed with a
drip in your arm and the caption it
happened Paul and Isaiah yeah so then
yeah and everything's like algorithm and
timing based and there's a lot of prep
that goes into the videos and I was like
I'm just gonna fall behind the schedule
I think you and if something that people
might know about us already maybe you
don't one thing that Paul and I bonded
on when it was past YouTube was we both
often suffer from anxiety we have a lot
of anxiety attacks we get in our own
heads and Beyond work and it's like if
there's personal stuff that is
overlapping and then it kind of converts
into doing more work so it was I think
just the anxiety just overtook my whole
body of like I gotta get so much but you
know us we just we often run on burnout
when we don't want to we love what we do
we love what we do in it and it's it's
our biggest treasure it's this is like
our baby in everything so we we do it
with the utmost love and then sometimes
we do it on burnout at the same time and
uh I I'm trying to learn to just
be more honest with myself and be honest
with others so that's going to be my my
my my resolution from 33 to 34 is just
to be more real with myself didn't start
off Smart though because I immediately
went to work the next day after the
hospital but I'm remembering yeah but I
wanted to I wanted to shout um someone
out who over the weekend they gave us a
a great post on Instagram uh rocket Fox
official it's our first fan art which
made me really happy because it was my
first sign that maybe I'm not going to
get replaced by Mt this week once I saw
the fan art I was like Yay it was such a
cool drawing we look so buff it's a very
accurate depiction of you not so
accurate of me the muscles on you very
very very well defined voluptuous oh
yeah that's what I'm talking about baby
yeah that's like yeah thank you rocket
Fox official but we got some stuff on
the agenda to talk about today man
and Paul's going to explain all of it
today we got to talk about the more
Barbie news are you are you not going to
watch this movie Paul I was talking to
you about it today and I feel like
you're not even gonna bother to watch
this movie we got more Barbie news and
then we could are you gonna watch it
maybe I'm 50 50 on Adam I mean if the
Wife puts it on I will but I'm not I'm
not actively seeking out going to watch
Barbie and it's nothing I just I don't
have any interest in the film I'm sorry
guys you know it's the same as like if
it's it's literally like a period piece
from the 1700s for me it's like that
region of lack of interest for me if it
had if I had Spider-Man in it I might
watch it but at the moment I don't know
and it's not it's nothing against the
movie I'm really glad it's doing well
it's just you know I only have so much
free time on my hands I'm either
watching movies all day for the channel
um or spending time with my family and
those brief moments that I get with my
family I don't know when I put on
another movie
um and if I'm doing it for work we're
not we're not going to cover Barbie
Barbie at the channel if I'm being
honest um just because we've got so many
movies from like 40 years ago that we
have to work through so yeah it I have
to either put something on at work and
work through it or go do some personal
stuff and yeah it's just I don't know
when I'm gonna get the time and that's
not and nothing against it I get
requested so many other films
um but yeah it's just I doubt I'm gonna
go out the way and watch it you know
what I mean
well I hope you eventually do watch I'll
let you know how it is Buddy and then we
got some conflicting Ahsoka viewing
figures James Gunn he's back in the news
for some old stuff he said Marvel delays
some streaming number reports and maybe
a couple of other things if we have the
time but since we just started talking
about Barbie what is this box office big
deal thingy that you were telling me
that you're trying to tell me about that
I did not open up the link for
yeah so Bobby has now passed a billion
it is the biggest movie of the year it
has passed by uh by Super Mario and
Oppenheimer has also passed 850 million
um probably gonna go on to get at least
900 million I'd say so it's a massive
crazy crazy success
um for for both Barbie and Oppenheimer
Barbie blew me away you know had
absolutely no idea how how big this
movie was gonna be massive hit
um I think it's one of Warner Brothers
biggest movies of all time as well so
yeah just incredible performance uh
Margot Robbie you know she's had a she's
had a number of flops in a row and to
see her get this it's been you know she
deserves it she's really carved out uh
space for herself in Hollywood and she's
a great actress as well she often gets
thought of as doing more sort of I don't
know she's not really like respected as
a big actress I don't feel she's more
kind of put in physical roles and more
franchise IPS stuff but yeah she's
really really good and yeah to see this
well done clap clap clap for for Margot
Robbie um because she pushed this movie
as much as she did and yeah it's done
absolutely brilliantly she should be
proud of herself
um yeah but the top three what's a very
interesting statistic is that the top
three movies of this year are Barbie
Marios number two and oppenheimer's
number three and this is the first time
since 2001 that the top three highest
grossing movies of a year haven't been
sequels so yeah times are changing we
might find Hollywood might be like oh we
better we better come up with some new
ideas but chances are these are all
gonna get sequels they're probably gonna
make Oppenheimer too
um I don't know how but they'll find a
way to do it and yeah we'll see what
happens next um but yeah brilliant
brilliant guys really proud of you you
know I I've prayed for days like this
because I don't think it's any secret
that I'm getting kind of
obviously I love comic book movies but I
feel they've hit a point where they're
very by the numbers and Studios you can
tell they're doing it for money reasons
rather than because they have an actual
idea you know so you've got to the point
that green lighting every single
Spider-Man villain spin-off movie
possible I don't think the one with Bad
Bunny the El murito one's happening
anymore but when that got green late it
was kind of like uh the the genre might
be getting milked a bit too much
um so yeah it's nice seeing that
originality can still be a thing that
pays off dividends and congratulations
guys you know every time we feel like
the movies have hit a point where
everything's the same you know these
films have come out and shown that you
can do something different and people
will support it if it's good enough yeah
you know I gotta say man like Mario and
I mean I didn't expect Barbie to be as
massive of a hit as it is I expected it
to be a hit Mario's no surprise like
that makes a lot of sense why it did so
well
Oppenheimer though it got me thinking
about how
you know where there's always this
conversation especially like around the
time when Tarantino was making those
criticisms about Marvel of how they
don't create movie stars and and that's
been a kind of a conversation even
before then of how movie stars are not
really around anymore they don't really
rely on actors and actresses to sell
films we go for the characters we go for
the IPS and it's kind of interesting
with what happened with Oppenheimer
because
it's Christopher Nolan and he's not a
movie star he's a director but he
actually has more Merit and weight I
think with audiences
Akin equivalent to what we kind of Miss
now from a movie star selling films
because Oppenheimer everything about it
does not reek of something that would
make up close to a billion dollars it's
R-rated it's three hours long it's
mainly people just talking in rooms
historical piece black and white as well
most black and white large parts of it
yeah that's what I mean like none of it
reads of a film that would come no I
don't think anyone really expected it to
come close to a billion dollars
and Christopher Nolan he is that name
that filmmaker who has weirdly that star
power that a lot of actual people in
front of the camera don't have anymore
and I think that's really really cool I
think that's really exciting and it's
awesome to see like the champion of
filmmakers for someone like him there's
not many people like him I know James
Cameron can do it and Christopher Nolan
can do it there's no one else really
that can pull that off now unless I'm
thinking of someone I was like Martin
Square says he I don't think could
monster says he's my favorite director
of all time but I don't even think he
can pull that off right now you know
like he can have a good hit they're
usually well regarded they're well
received but to be a box office
phenomenon
uh Nolan and James Cameron are the only
two I feel like I'm missing one but
Nolan and James Cameron are the two I
can think of
yeah and when you were I've often heard
that comment about how you know there's
no more movie stars and when you were
talking about there it actually struck
me that Nolan's the name but he brings
the stars with him as well when you
think about all of the the people that
featured in this film because they
wanted to work with Nolan just the fact
that Nolan's involved brings people on
board so I think pushing Nolan is like
oh crap well you know there's gonna be
people like the amount of people that
were in Oppenheimer that I didn't even
know were in the film and and just
seeing like like Casey Affleck show up
and I don't even think I knew Josh Hart
who was in it to be honest I did not
know either and just yeah and seeing
them pop up it's like oh crap and the
fact is Nolan brings the stars with him
to the point where it's almost like
you're you're going because his name's
on it and there's almost like this
entire group of people that he could be
bringing with him and there's all the
people that want to work with him which
again elevates the movie so yeah I'm
he's gonna go farther that Christopher
Nolan well it's funny because when I was
looking back on the marketing with my
recollection correct me if I'm wrong
Robert Downey Jr is easily the biggest
star out of that whole cast or at least
the most you know it's probably the most
well paid and whatnot and in the
marketing they didn't even really use
him a lot probably because most of his
scenes are in black and white in that
film so they didn't showcase him a lot
in the actual trailers so I didn't even
expect him to be in the movie for as
long as he's in he takes up a lot like
one of the main story lines is is him
he's like the main supporting character
and they didn't even rely on his star
power and Killian Murphy is by no means
like now he is probably but before this
I wouldn't consider him like the A-list
star to sell a movie you know and now
this just skyrocketed him to be
something that much more prolific it's
really cool man it's it's really really
awesome I'm happy for all three films
and it's awesome to see how this is all
going
too bad Disney can't quite be need it
they got lots of viewing figures from
those movies but there's been a bit of
back and forth on viewing figures Greg
when we talk about the Ahsoka Premiere
now Samba TV they're known for they're
known for basically
um
judging viewer viewership by certain
things that they select for example
they've got a sample size of 28 million
and so it's not a small sample size and
what they tend to do is if someone
watches past the the first five minutes
of a show I believe and they register
that as a view and that counts towards
basically you know what what the
viewership of a show is and you can use
that to judge how popular something is
now Ahsoka uh its first two episodes
dropped obviously and according to Sama
TV 1.2 million us households watch the
premiere of um a Sakura over its first
six days on Disney plus now
you know the Internet it's all over the
place
um but just going off that metric alone
it didn't seem very good because that is
quite low now I'm going to bring up some
of the numbers and we're going to kind
of compare so um the first episode of
Loki was 2.5 million Moon Knight was 1.8
million Falcon in the Winter Soldier was
1.8 million one division was 1.6 and
Hawkeye was 1.5 you're going up of Samba
right Samba TV yeah so yeah so that was
Osama TV now House of the Dragon 4.8
million absolutely amazing show
um crazy audience and people notice that
you know the way it's been worded in the
summer thing is that it was over the
first six days for Ahsoka so 1.2 million
over the first six days now all those
other shows that I've listed they were
actually the first four days so it felt
like there's been something you know
it's not really performed that well and
judging by that sample size that we
talked about before
I I feel that was quite bad and it has
been you know reflected in our
viewership as well I'm sure Greg you
know I don't mind like I'm sure you
don't mind me saying this but our soccer
videos haven't performed at the level
that something like Loki has for example
there that hasn't it's barely trended
they obviously moved it to a new release
time slot which the sons of a
um but it should have had that boost
from obviously premiering at 9pm in New
York oh 9 9 p.m Eastern Standard Time in
America and it still didn't really get a
boost from that so it's had the
advantage of having six days for a
Premiere and a good time slot as well
it's not dropping middle of the night in
America now what's happened is that kind
of
took up all the headlines for the first
day and then the next day Disney for the
first time ever put out a press
statement saying that Ahsoka had
actually received 15 million views yeah
which they then corrected almost
immediately after saying actually it was
14 million views so so there's kind of
this back and forth over what's going on
with it
um personally I tend to lean more
towards the samba TV being the more
realistic figure obviously I still get
it to 28 million sample size it's not
covering things worldwide which I think
Disney would take into account yeah
definitely now you know streaming
services they never really release these
numbers and it did feel like damage
control
um because I don't feel like had that
number on Samba TV being so low that
they would have came out and done this I
think if it had been up towards Loki or
even Falcon the Winter Soldier at 1.8
million they would have probably have
you know just left it at that and not
done anything so it does kind of feel
like damage control because Star Wars in
general you know let's be honest there's
people who though the love it the group
collecting all the toys watching the
original trilogy bought the special
editions went out to watch the prequels
there's still a part of them that wants
to see Star Wars fail and that's let's
just say people like um the leadership
that might be involved at lucasfilms a
certain figure that they might not like
and might want to get fired so it's kind
of difficult to to judge stuff because
there's always confirmation bias where
you'll see a big account that wants to
see Star Wars fail pulling out a certain
article or sample size that proves that
it's doing badly and if you want to see
it do well they'll pull out something
that makes it look good for example the
viewing figures now what do you think
happened in regards to this Greg because
I I sort of have a feeling that it's
somewhere down the middle well I think
you're a hundred percent right first off
that this is damage control Disney stock
is the worst it's been in a very very
long time their reputation is tanking
the amount of money that they have lost
on their films has been kind of
astronomical right like they've had
they've had either flops or films that
just underperformed quantumania Little
Mermaid Elemental Indiana Jones Haunted
Mansion secret Invasion did not do that
well Marvel's is not exactly tracking
that great right now
and then of course with Ahsoka I think
that number circulating which is ringing
as another oh my God Disney is
underperforming and like you brought up
that Disney's numbers they might
include viewership from all over the
world and I guess the question is coming
down to
what counts as viewership right now
because that's such a drastic difference
right to go from like 1.6 was 1.6 is
that what you said 1.2 1.2 to 14 million
is an insane like Gap in in difference
in numbers and
I don't know what the like the match
because like we know how Samba
um counts their numbers they tend to go
off U.S households right and they have
to go off of the households that have
the tracking software installed as well
and it's it's just us whereas Disney
might be in counting the number of times
it was actually streamed and like who
might have watched it repetitively it's
really strange
but when I look at the number even for
the ones where Ahsoka has actually done
really well for like certain YouTube
like I'm not saying YouTube channels are
the end-all be-all to determine it but
it is a it's it's a relatively
reasonable metric to kind of see where
engagement is really at for a show and
yeah like it doesn't really take the top
spot on trending it's never gone
trending in the way how Mandalorian has
ever gone trending it's never gone
trending in the way a lot of the Marvel
stuff that you listed has gone trending
not even close not not even remotely
close to it
so
I I can't recall though do you know has
this ever happened before where Disney
has because this was like a PR release
like I got the email too where Disney
released this email I was like this is
kind of strange and it read a little bit
it read a little sad to me honestly like
it reads a little desperate to to save
themselves uh from the the image that
has been tarnished significantly this
year and I I guess I feel I don't I
guess I feel bad for them I'm kind of I
am kind of worried I don't feel bad for
the corporation Greg you feel bad for
the creatives I feel bad for the
creatives and I feel bad as a fan that's
what it is like I feel sad as a as a fan
because you know we love
we we grew our we grew our business
doing this stuff and the way how our
business grew is because we already had
that reverence we already had that love
we already had that shared Nostalgia the
way how a lot of audience audience
members have had with these properties
Marvel DC Star Wars those three brands
right there
they're all three have not been doing
good and if we're just talking about
this one like Star Wars especially I I
can I can flash back to when
you know the announcement of force
awakens and then bringing back the
original cast and everything that they
were planning on doing and it was just
so exciting and even that first Force
awakens trailer like I remember the the
love and the hype I remember it all
I remember where I was when I watched
that trailer yeah which is a rare thing
I was in my grandma's house
um and I was just sitting on the sofa
and then I got the notification saying
it was out and I just stood up and went
to the bathroom like almost like I was
doing something funny in there uh I had
to use some tissues for the tears
running down my face because I I think I
was probably one of the only trailers
I've ever cried over and it was a bit at
the end with Han Solo and Chewbacca
saying we're back and it just it just
hit me was like oh they've done it
they've done it take my money this one
this franchise is never gonna die yeah
that's that's what I mean is that's
what's the part that is disheartening
about it to me is as I know there's a
lot of videos and we obviously a lot of
our videos lately have led with a bit of
uh of a negative slant but I think we
like to have a nuanced conversation
about it and if I'm being completely
honest the part that makes me sad is I I
wish the I wish the love was still kind
of a predominant Force if you will where
now it's it's it seems like it's on a
it's on a decline and it's struggling to
really stay relevant and and alive when
I like Ahsoka a lot I there's there's a
lot of Ahsoka that I really do love I I
love a lot of it and a lot of people
feel like this is more Star Wars than it
ever has been in a long time I really
really enjoy it and I hope that
the love comes around for it and more
importantly I hope that the show ends up
sticking the landing by the time it
concludes I I hope it's actually really
good and so yeah that's that's kind of
my main Takeaway on it is I I think
they're trying to save face right now
because they have a lot of big plans as
well and they want to stick through with
those plans and they might have to can a
lot of those plans if this does not get
better
well that's the thing with these viewing
figures if this was a network cable TV
show they would probably cancel it in
all honesty
um because the viewership's so low and
obviously you know it's in a prime time
slot on a Tuesday night as well and this
is you know okay cable TV and network TV
they want to sell adverts and if you've
not got the viewership there you can't
charge more for adverts so you know
moving it across to that it probably
would be canceled obviously you know
it's on a streaming service so that they
can decide what they want to do for it
but we know this is very much a platform
that Dave filoni's gonna launch what's
probably going to be the next phase of
Star Wars after the sequel Trilogy film
wise obviously he's got his movie coming
out which is speculated to be uh to the
Empire and that's obviously going to be
very thrawn Centric which it makes me
kind of surprised they've not teased
thrawn earlier I don't know if we're
going to get him in episode four or
whatever but I feel like he should have
been there from the start almost in the
series and you should have seen things
from his point of view as well but
disregarding all that
um there's a lot of things going on and
I think the main thing why I also tend
to lean more towards Samba is because
Disney can pick and choose what they
classes of you and they can obviously
inflate the numbers like if if you ask
me what my viewership is like what my
average view on a video is when I'm
trying if a company you know sometimes
companies come to me and they're like
well want to put an advert in one of
your videos what are your views like at
the moment uh I'll I'll select the best
three videos and go look that's we do
that all the time um and I think when
you can select your own viewership what
you define as a view that's obviously
gonna you know you're gonna try and play
your hand and just the 15 million change
to the 14 million made me feel like they
never had a true grasp on the figure and
it's almost like they asked someone in
the office or like what go on go on a
soccer and see what the views are
because they are 15 million or something
um and then the next minute that I
actually use 14 million knock that back
it just seems weird that you'd read your
15 as sorry you'd read 14 is 15 you know
what I mean it seems like a weird
mistake to make but these things happen
um in PR now the fan gesture actually
put together a really really good thread
and talking about how the Ahsoka viewing
figures weren't really adding up and
they kind of went over you know a lot of
shows up that we actually know the
viewership for to compare what Ahsoka
would be and where it would sit if these
views are indeed definite and so House
of the Dragon which became HBO's log
look sorry House of the Dragon became
HBO's largest Premiere in over a decade
that Premiere earned just about 10
million viewers the show drew the
largest audience in the pay TV channel's
history including before the streaming
era HBO now HBO Go and HBO Max
um so going off what the largest HBO
show is
it's 10 million viewers so that would
mean Ahsoka is one of the largest uh TV
biggest TV shows especially premieres of
all time and if you kind of compare the
samba figures for that as well obviously
House of the Dragon was 4.8 million in
four days whereas ahsoka's 1.2 million
in six days so it's a bit bit weird on
that
um so House of the Dragon also trended
on social media at number one for 14
hours straight The Last of Us Premiere
was also HBO's second highest Premiere
in the last 13 years it beat out Game of
Thrones and the first episode earned 4.7
million viewers so that's the second
biggest show at 4.7 million and Ahsoka
is doing 14 million you know what I mean
no wow doesn't seem like it they're
using the same viewership to understand
that um so the 14
million views you know comparing it to
to Game of Thrones and The Last of Us it
seems it seems like something fishy is
going on there seems like a bit of PR
spin
um and yeah it's it's kind of a it's a
weird thing I get I get there trying to
sell at the show's successful and
that'll obviously be enthusiastic like
I'll admit sometimes even if I like
something if it doesn't do well I'll get
kind of bogged down with like negativity
around that project almost like Blue
Beetle is a perfect example really enjoy
the film
um in this weekend they're like
it's it's past 100 million worldwide I'm
like oh that's doing that's like quite
bad and then I'll start thinking like oh
like when you hear the flashes like we
we enjoyed the flash but you know
hearing it's one of the biggest flops
ever it's like oh it's quite quite quite
bad and you get kind of pulled into the
memeing on it and talking about it
and I feel like they want to avoid that
by having it come out as a success
because if they hadn't in those viewing
Figures were the the first thing that
people saw like the samba TV number
people might be memeing on it and
tearing it down which I can get I get
why they're doing it you know Disney's
in a very difficult place at the moment
mainly down to themselves let's be
honest I don't think it's I don't think
fans you know we we were all happily
gonna throw money Disney's way if they
were killing it like I'll I'll clear out
space on my wall for Funko Pops from
Marvel and Star Wars all day if they're
delivering really good products but I
feel like they've kind of slipped and
they they probably know they have as
well I mean there's so much the
viewerships there
um like we we'll have periods on our
YouTube channel where we'll uh we'll see
viewership go down and we'll be like oh
we're kind of messing up right now and
it often we'll take a step back and
we'll analyze what's happening and we'll
make certain changes improve on certain
things and what we'll see follow from
that is a boost in viewership and I
think they need to just do that instead
of you know maybe spinning the numbers
and trying to figure trying to convince
us that something's not wrong instead of
just being like look let's admit the
problem which lucasfilm and Disney don't
really seem to do that well like there's
never really much accountability almost
like Indiana Jones was a massive flop
and no one's really you know ah like to
me that's crazy that no one's been fired
over that one spent 300 million on that
movie and Kathleen Kennedy's still
heading up the company after numerous
flops like the theory that she must know
where the bodies are
that must be true because there's no way
any other executive would survive that
so yeah a bit strange
um not been a good year for Disney and I
think they're just trying to spin it I
mean I imagine behind the scenes they
obviously know it it's it's a bigger
Sorkin movie that's happening behind the
scenes or they're all just debating and
yelling at each other and mad but they
have to there's so much writing on the
line man like when it comes to their
stock and they have like so many
investors and whatnot it's there's
there's so there's just way too much
writing on the line here so they they
have to say face as much as possible
this has been a they they they have not
really known how to play the pandemic
after the pandemic to now and then
what's going on with the strikes as well
it's it's really bad rhetoric all around
of what's Happening Here they've had a
couple of really good things but for the
most part like any any of their hits
that they've had has not been enough to
supplement the amount of loss that
they've had I just don't see how that's
possible with the amount they've had to
remove from their Disney plus and just
all the numbers that have been reported
no knowing how much this costs
there's no way that they've
I feel like they've just lost a lot of
money this year it's really been bad for
them so yeah hopefully he gets to keep
his job by bike hopefully hopefully yeah
Daddy Eiger
but the reason that the text on the
thumbnail is caught red-handed is sort
of because of these viewing figures
getting meddled a bit with allegedly if
anyone from Disney any Liars are
watching this we're just speculating
we're not out and out saying you you've
uh you've fiddled the numbers there but
someone else who got caught red-handed
bloody James gone on Facebook 11 years
ago they went back they went back in
time on James Gunn's Facebook and they
found uh some let's say less than
Pleasant comments about Tim Burton's
Batman and Christopher Nolan's Batman
Begins yeah and the Dark Knight as well
actually so he slagged off both Burton
films and both Nolan ones at the time
which were the Dark Knight and Batman
Begins so yeah um
bit of a weird thing like
I'm kind of in two minds over this I
think uh if you're going back through 11
years worth of posts you might have a
bit of an agenda
um and I'll say what I said at the time
when this first got announced I see
people talking like this every day on
Twitter and they also think they can run
DC so he's just someone who's done that
but he's got in the position where he
can actually do this now I'm gonna read
out the the quotes that he said
um and yeah these we'll we'll talk about
how these almost got debunked but then
it has kind of come out that it was
actually his account
um and he's not actually denied saying
these but we'll go into it all you
you're not going anywhere are you mate
he tried to spin it in a way
the way I saw his post before we start
recording and the way he made the post
at first I was like oh this must be him
debunking it and then when I read it I'm
like oh he's not debunking it at all
it's just when you read it look at it
upon first impression you might think
that and that's kind of the point of
what he did but no it's not debunking it
uh I I 100 believe these are real
should should I stop I'll stop and get
your reaction to each point that he
makes so why not Keaton did have a
ridiculous voice that said I'd rather
put up with a ridiculous voice than
horrible action sequences and acting
barely worthy of a Batman TV show
so that's not too bad I would say
now B point B
point B I have no idea how you can think
that Burton's Batman has more
similarities with Mauro Millers Batman
and Joker than Nolan does and listen I
have problems with both of Nolan's films
I don't think either one is a classic
and I don't even think Batman Begins as
good but they're far superior to the
first Batman
yeah I mean I think that aesthetically
they're closer to foreign
yeah so the when he says the both the
Nolan films this is because this
happened during a time where the Dark
Knight Rises hadn't been released uh
just to I was a bit annoyed by that but
um pointy none of your defenses get by
the fact that despite being the first
cinematic dark take on Batman so what
Stallone's Judge Dread was the first
take on Judge Dredd the movie is awful
oh yeah and Jack Nicholson as the Joker
is Jack Nicholson in The Shining with
shitty clown makeup you everyone
involved with that travesty this is Tim
Burton Batman
the Tim Burton Batman is poorly written
the soundtrack is the worst work of
everyone involved the soundtrack that's
the best bit and it's absolutely one of
the most boring films ever not only that
but the reveal of the Joker is the
killer of Bruce Wayne's parents spits in
the face of Batman's origin and is a
nullification of the bottomless thirst
for vengeance that necessarily drives
Batman it pretends not to be campy but
is completely so and on top of
everything the dark creature of the
night can't even move his neck
give me a break it's ridiculous
awful film Burton's Planet of the Apes
is genius in comparison this this sounds
like the countless people that I have
grown up in LA and grown up in the film
Circle
and then now with the internet
this just sounds like a bunch of
countless people who love to be
contrarians and egg people on this is
just reads like Film School student
level of just trying to piss off people
look ma'am honestly
I'm gonna put a disclaimer in Greg the
James Gunn's 57 years old now so you
know we go back 11. 46 when this
happened yeah now I appreciate that
that's what's funny to me about it is
he's 46 acting like this
um
look man
is 11 years ago and I'll be honest a
part of me a part of me feels for him on
this I'm not gonna lie I I can't lie and
I know I often say something here that
eggs on people in the comments who
already really don't like me and I'll be
honest I part of me feels for him on
this because it was 11 years ago
and
you know at I don't know what state of
mind this guy was in at the time of
viewing these things there are movies
I've seen a few years ago that I that I
liked quite a bit and then I re-watched
them sometimes he doesn't even take me a
few years to rewatch him sometimes
rewatch them a little bit later on like
a couple weeks I'm like I don't know
what I was thinking I don't like that
movie at all and then sometimes I don't
like something and then I re-watch it uh
or I like all right change movies are
not just a
um analytical experience I don't think
they ought to be some people just view
movies that way I think that there's a
little bit both of an analytical and an
emotional experience and I remember like
I would say 10 years ago or so that's
all I used to be was mainly from just
just from my head I would just kind of
just only watch things from an
analytical point of view and not really
go off how my heart is feeling
and
so I'm not saying James Gunn's opinion
has changed or not like maybe it has
maybe maybe it hasn't whatever uh so I
don't really know what to make of this
in terms of this if this opinion is
still the thing that he actually holds
part of me sounds like he's just trying
to egg it on that's giving the benefit
of the doubt the other part of me that
feels for him on this is the fact that
this version of James Gunn was not the
James Gunn that was aspiring to be he it
was it didn't sound like until very
recently was he even considering
becoming a CEO you know was even
becoming someone who is in charge of
running a major Studio you know and like
this is not the language of someone who
would run a studio essentially DC of all
places right like this is just a
filmmaker uh from coming from the trauma
days the guy who made like Slither and
stuff like that like this and and super
the ones who would have these kind of
controversial opinions and have these
contrarian takes and whatnot uh is he
and he seems like he's also changed as a
person and my point being is this is
that a lot of the times when it comes to
to movies and I don't know if his
opinion has changed I have no
idea if it has
I think when we change as people when we
grow as people and whatnot and obviously
James Gunn has had a lot of crazy life
experiences that have caused him to
reflect and change as a human being that
our opinions on movies and stuff can
change so I think it's just kind of
weird to really
hold someone super accountable for what
they're gonna do with the future of DC
based off their opinion that was laid
out on Facebook when he was obviously in
an argument with someone like
11 years ago because
who knows how he really feels about it
today and does is this really going to
affect the way how the DC movies
ultimately play out it's like does this
mean Guardians of the Galaxy was were
bad was a bad Trilogy no does this mean
this movie The Suicide Squad was
suddenly bad no the guy clearly knows
what he's doing when it comes to these
properties
um and maybe I don't you get where I'm
going with this I like that's just my
opinion I don't have this like outrage
do I agree with okay do you want to know
if I agree with this no I don't agree
with what he's saying here like this
take I don't agree with but I'm not mad
about it like this is not none of this
is something I haven't heard before you
know what I mean
um yeah so yeah I'm not pissed about it
at all and I feel like there's a lot of
love for Batman Returns especially that
has come out of the woodwork in the last
10 years you know like it used to just
be the like Batman and now Batman
Returns gets like so much love and a lot
of people praise that as even better
than Batman 89.
um so yeah I don't I don't agree with
with this assessment I personally prefer
Batman Returns just a little side note I
I actually prefer that over Batman 89.
you idiot so yeah I'm kind of all over
the place for this so I I don't think
people should be going back 11 years
with of posts on Facebook and not even
11 years worth like these were nestled
deep in comments so you would have had
to go through every single post read all
the comments go through every single
post read all the comments so I think
that's a bit you know if you're doing
that then you're probably gonna uncover
something eventually especially when you
go like something I've said something
problematic I've probably said Burton's
Batman well I don't I haven't but
um I would have said something about
another like I love those movies too
much to ever say anything bad about them
but another movie that I might say I end
up becoming the head of Marvel in the
next 20 years I might have said Captain
Marvel or something wasn't that good you
know what I mean yeah um Incredible Hulk
I quite enjoyed the first thought didn't
really enjoy that much don't know if
I've ever put that on Twitter but
someone might dig it up now my my other
thing with this is that they actually
started blaming the Snyder cult now I I
love Snyder's movies but I've also got
to the point where I will argue with
people about them and be like look may
it it's fine you can like them but don't
argue with people who who don't all day
because it's a waste of time you're
never going to convince someone like
this movies they'll be like well you're
not you're not a real fighter for the
cause I'm like you shouldn't be fighting
mate it's just a movie that you're
talking about
um but they got blamed for it and it's
like well I don't know if 11 years ago
people who liked Snyder's movies back in
2012 before he ever made Man of Steel
were thinking about you know how to ruin
James Gunn's career 11 years from now in
case he's the the head of DC so I I
throw that conspiracy theory that there
was the Snyder people behind it as well
um however I do think that to run DC
almost need to have like an obsessive
love for it and you know love both it's
good and bad almost and maybe recognize
where this stuff's been bad but like
Batman and Robin
I I love that movie I recognize it's you
know not everyone's favorite and I
recognize it it's very bad but I love it
if that makes sense and yeah just to see
him saying this stuff about batman89 and
the Nolan films it didn't like out and
out bother me because I'm not really
someone who gets offended by stuff
especially like comic book movie stuff I
mean you can say like you could say the
Godfather's which is like my
favorite movie ever and I wouldn't be
offended by I don't really care that
much
um
but just seeing him saying that and then
also in the same year that he says the
flash is one of the greatest comic book
movies of all time it's it's more kind
of like James you put your foot in it so
many times over the years that it's just
it's gonna have such a difficult time
dealing with all this stuff I think
because the fan base is just so rabid
with DC you have to be you have to
basically be Batman oh a white knight
that is just well a dark knight will say
a dark knight that's completely devoid
of imperfection a symbol someone who
unites everything behind a certain mind
State and yeah guns just for him to be
doing that in his late 40s it's kind of
like man you were really immature for a
lot of your life and like I wouldn't be
going on like that even now I wouldn't
be crying ranting about how stuff
is it'd just be
sitting in a chair sort of doing it in a
very monotone voice and not really
getting amped up about it but yeah it's
it's a bit of a weird one obviously he's
been caught so what happened was he came
out and well someone said that he
deleted his Facebook page over it
um and what God then debunked was that
he hadn't actually deleted his Facebook
page because he hadn't logged into
Facebook for so long and he'd actually
tried to do it and had a had a report of
suspicious activity or something now
would that person have been able to go
back 11 years and change posts no so
what people were saying was well he said
that he's tried to he he he's denied
deleting the page basically and but he
hasn't actually denied creating the
posts 11 years ago in the first place so
I think they were real
you know I think with with gun if you're
a fan oh this sounds like something
James Gunn would have said like back in
yeah I mean it sounds like something he
would have said he's got all those
tweets as well like he got fired for and
people still are you know there's some
people who just will never forgive him
for for saying that stuff
um I think if you're with James Gooden
but you've got to be you're in for a
penny you're in for for a pound I don't
know if that's a saying in America I'm
guessing not but it basically means if
you're in for a cent you're in full or a
dollar is that what it would translate
to but it means you're going for one
thing you've got to take the whole
everything with it both good and bad
um so yeah if you if you support James
go and then I'm sure this won't matter
if you don't like James good and this is
just gonna be fuel to the fire where
you're like I guess Nolan's
I I guess my question I'll just ask you
did does these two does this concern you
does this add any concern for you
regarding the the future of DC
specifically this threat does it
actually cause concern
no in all honesty when it comes to guns
film I even Blue Beetle flopping you
know the flash flopping if Aquaman flops
all that stuff doesn't necessarily deter
it because I still want to see the film
um Superman Legacy and if that's good
then I think that'll shut up a lot of
the the doubters
um and it'll kind of ease my feelings
that and and I'm just I'm just trying to
be like well give the guy this what this
chance
is putting us all into Superman Legacy
if it's good then yeah just see that so
just everything like these comments
whatever if the movie's good yeah who
cares about this stuff if it's bad then
stuff like this is obviously going to
get pulled out again and it'll be like
well he said this and he said the flash
was the greatest film of all time and
stuff like that will always get
constantly pulled out about him and just
every move he's made really has been a
weird one I think personally like
announcing his slate when he didn't need
to causing all these other films to to
feel like no one needed to go and see
them yeah I I think all that stuff's
gonna get pulled back up if Superman
Legacy is bad if it's good it'll all be
forgotten about and no one will care and
I'm just kind of trying to give him that
one chance I I think that our I'm not
saying James Gunn's one of our greatest
filmmakers I think he is a great
filmmaker I think he's a fantastic
filmmaker I'm I'm not going to say he's
one of the greatest of all time but if I
think if you look at a lot of people
renowned as the greatest
filmmakers of all time they usually they
usually have a take on something that
people love that comes out and they're
that it's it totally goes against what a
lot of the audiences feel we've seen it
in the superhero landscape with a lot of
well-regarded filmmakers Legends of you
know filmmakers who have said stuff
about a lot of the films that a lot of
us really do love I mean I I wasn't even
thinking about terrorizing Scorsese
Spielberg Fincher I'm thinking about
like Tarantino I was I remember he was
on a I forget which podcast he was on
but he was bitching about the movie 1917
which is an amazing film everyone loves
that movie he was bitching about that
movie and really criticizing it
and I remember there was even one year
where he put the Lone Ranger as one of
his top 10 movies of that year a movie
that so many people hated
so people a lot of the times these
filmmakers who have unique Visions tend
to have
not the usual takes on things as well
and that's a lot of the time a thing
that can help contribute to them to
having a little bit of to me in some
ways this kind of gives me a bit of
confidence
that he'll have
a unique Direction you know like he'll
be able to bring something unique that
we haven't seen done before
yes I I do wish this was more of a
positive sentiment don't get me wrong
like it's kind of a bummer to hear about
these things
at the same time though I'm not at all
like it does it does not add any level
of worry to what the future of DC is
ultimately gonna look like when it comes
to like these Batman characters and
stuff so
it's just the way it is it's the way
life goes man yeah it's a funny old time
for comic book movies and we've also
been hit with some bad news from Marvel
as they're delaying a lot of their
Disney plus slate Greg have you got the
image would you like to go through the
delays oh do I have the image
Paul did not send this to me I I totally
got it right here
so okay Loki season two is still coming
out October 6th
what if season two is coming out
Christmas is it actual Christmas I don't
want to spend my Christmas watching
around Christmas they said I'm not I'm
not taking Christmas day off for what if
happy Hogan Saved Christmas you know
what I mean X-Men 97 early 2024 which
reportedly is going to have animation
style more akin to what if
Agatha is new title of title number 14.
ironheart has been Agatha is to late
2024. ironheart has been delayed Wonder
Man is delayed and Daredevil born again
is delayed well they need to spread
their out they don't they're gonna
there's gonna be a dry period
so they they got to spread some of this
out man
um I mean it looks like nothing's
canceled though
I realized when they did they did this
list because I hadn't actually seen it
all in one list together and I realized
I just don't really give a about
most of these projects
um but might be a bit rude saying it but
is Echo still coming out
yeah Echo has been pushed back to
January I believe
um so which I find strange because they
were going to dump it all on one day and
that seemed to me like they were just
going to rip the Band-Aid on it they
realized that it might not be good might
not be worth dragging it out but now
they're they're pushing it to to January
um so we've only actually had two marble
shows this year
um secret Invasion and Loki I believe
was there wasn't one in January or so
yeah so just the two which is crazy to
think about because if you told us at
the start of 2023 like you're only
getting two Marvel shows this year would
be like oh no I'm gonna cover for the
whole year we'll have to start doing
exit
breakdowns um but it's worked out for
the best but yeah that's what we're
thinking about it
um but yeah there's been Lots we're
Quantum Mania though and we're Guardians
right yeah so yeah movies don't count
though
Disney Plus shows
um now
when I read this list I thought it's a
bit mental that they're they're doing
these projects still when they've got
the rights to the X-Men and I thought
back to when they bought Fox and I
thought you know the X-Men is like the
perfect thing to do Disney Plus shows
about you've got lots of different
mutants that they can do spin-off series
on whilst keeping the main family
together and then I started thinking
about all the different Disney Plus
shows they could do and the fact that we
never got the Captain America returning
the times returning the Infinity Stones
we never got a Disney plus series on
that that is crazy I mean every week
could have been a different time period
every week could have been a different
Stone every week could have been
different heroes and villains and they
messed it up and didn't do that now
people were like oh well the budget
would have been insane
like you they spent like 225 million on
secret Invasion yeah that's that's the
cost of a normal Marvel movie I'm sure
they could have done that with a TV show
um obviously Chris Evans had kind of
stepped away but when he talks and you
know the guy's doing like apple plus
movies with uh Anna diarmus that no one
watches so yeah I feel like he probably
would have come back now just thinking
about stuff as a whole I think what's
probably happened with all the all these
Disney plus Marvel shows like let's be
honest
you know how excited are people for all
of these there'll be some like Daredevil
um you know what if but are people
excited for Agatha who who's you know
was a spin-off One Division character
and I think what's probably happened is
that you know marvel
I've been told by Disney that they need
as many shows as possible to push their
streaming platform they obviously you
know Guardians of the Galaxy was a
perfect example of how Marvel could take
obscure characters turn them into
a-listers and make money and they
thought you know they've clearly thought
that's something they can do over and
over and over again
um and obviously I think they saw how
popular One Division was which it was it
was a really Big Show and feige to me he
was basically told to green light as
many shows as possible rather than that
really being the plan for the off now I
might be wrong on that
um but I personally don't think that
when Fergie was building towards Secret
Wars and you know bringing the X-Men
into that he he would have sat down and
thought well you know what else I
think's worth doing Agatha dark hole
Diaries or whatever different title
every other month but I I we we're going
towards Secret Wars but we've really
gotta make sure Agatha shows off the
ground before that and
um that that to me sounds more like a
mandate from Disney being like we've got
a streaming service we need content
Agatha's a very popular character from
One Division we need the show on Disney
plus now go
now I think this just kind of speaks to
the problem that Disney have in general
with Disney plus and that is that
they're streaming site needs content
rather than necessarily having ideas and
we're starting to see with Star Wars as
well where you know they're putting out
things like the acolyte uh and or Ahsoka
you know potentially all well ando's
definitely a great show but you know
Ahsoka remains to be seen as does the
Acolyte and it feels like
you know if these were films would you
necessarily be green lighting them but
when it's a streaming service and you
need to have content for that then
they're gonna green light a lot more
than they need to because the the
service needs content
um and I I feel like the difference
between Disney plus that that is a
really smaller point because yeah when
our premiere shows were one division
Loki and felt like these were big
characters a-listers yeah yeah that's a
really strong point
yeah and I think what Disney are doing
that Netflix don't so Netflix will just
take lots of new shows create shows and
they'll create like so many of them and
if they do well they'll make more
seasons if they don't do well cancel
them move on who cares
um but Disney stuff's so connected to
Big IPS so they they can't cancel it
like Ahsoka if that was on Netflix that
would be canceled 100 Ahsoka would be
canceled if it was on Netflix but
because Disney you know it's a Star Wars
property building towards films coming
out down the line Disney have to ride
with it and I feel like the the problem
that that you know Disney have that
Netflix don't is Netflix will just go
out get you know upcoming writers will
go to them with and Pitch an idea
they'll take it on board and do it
whereas Disney seem to be milking from
their current IPS and thus they're
killing interest in them uh and I think
they're declining viewership should be a
wake-up call to them but that seems to
be the difference I I don't really feel
like someone will go to Disney plus and
pitch uh you know and Agatha show I
think what will happen is Marvel and
Disney will instead go out looking for
someone to write an AG of the show
whereas Netflix someone will go into the
office I've got an idea for a film or a
movie do you like it and uh yeah you
know what we'll get we we see the
potential in this we'll give it a go
whereas
they seem like they're they're forcing
the content out rather than the content
coming to them and I think when I just
saw this lineup and I I really delay
these for however long give me Daredevil
yeah but the rest of them just they're
obviously happy to keep kicking the can
down the road
um and I just feel like it doesn't you
know that they're not that bothered
about releasing them which makes me I
mean how many times has Agatha been
delayed and how many times has had its
title changed now variety came out and
said that
they were doing this on purpose and it
was part of Agatha's Shenanigans and
it's like is it though because every
time the show gets delayed it seems like
it's got a new title along with it so is
it or is it you know you're just trying
to make excuses Disney savings
they're talking to variety we're doing
this on purpose hey put that out there
we're doing this on purpose
who made the CGI in the Chrono Bowl bad
on purpose it's that kind of thing
um and I I just feel like Disney's kind
of a snake eating its own tail it's an
oroboros which is it's just you know
it's it's eating enough to to last that
day but eventually it's gonna just run
out of tail and it's fully consumed
itself and that's what it feels like I
mean what happens what happens if Marvel
and Star Wars die what is Disney plus
gonna do like we've already seen a big
decline in viewership in both of them
Marvel can probably go until Secret Wars
pretty I would say pretty well they'll I
think they'll last you know I think
they'll get City viewership until Secret
Wars and then people want to see how
that is
and then it'll probably be more
difficult to start up again but
obviously if they start on the right
foot with the X-Men and that it could do
well Star Wars on the other hand though
you know what what can they do really I
mean once you've had the Mandalorian
season two which brought back Boba Fett
brought a soccer into live action
brought back bogatan
ended with a Luke Skywalker Cameo that
was like the I remember every single
week with Mandalorian season two was
like oh crap who's gonna turn up this
week and then just to end on Luke it was
like oh this is crazy
and what now what can they do from that
they they brought back Luke for Book of
Boba Fett I mean that I had a boost but
it wasn't a massive thing to to
Skyrocket the viewership and it just
feels like it Disney just really need to
change how they run their streaming
platform because Netflix are gonna
completely kill them they are the king
of the streamers because they have the
right strategy which is to create new
shows and new IPS that bring people to
Netflix whereas Disney's is we have
these several IPS here's some shows on
them Netflix just came out with an
adaptation of One Piece which is a
phenomenon right now it's a huge hit
and like the thing is Netflix like green
light significantly more than Disney
plus so I think that's why they they're
more likely to can something if it gets
like the Ahsoka Samba TV numbers because
they're like well we got so much money
like spent on so many other things that
we can't afford to keep this around
because because of the the vast amount
of other properties and products like
there's just so much on Netflix that's
always releasing every week then I'm
like I don't even know what this is It's
I like that every single week I have no
idea and not only that they're also like
acquiring rights to shows to also air on
Netflix as well uh so there's there's so
much going on with Netflix but you're
absolutely right man when it comes to
Disney plus because you know they they
tried when they tried premiering Disney
plus yeah the Mandalorian was the big
thing to get excited about the fact that
they were gonna put like the Vault on
there all these other all the Disney
movies and stuff would all be there then
they try to some things like the Jeff
Goldblum show
um the world according to Jeff Goldblum
I want to call it uh
uh which I think was I didn't see it but
maybe people liked it sometimes I try
these like documentary shows like with
celebrities that they was that the
Jeremy Renner one and the Chris
Hemsworth I believe that was Disney plus
I I think so
it and it's because like Disney all
around it doesn't really have too much
to rely on when you look at all their
main Brands Pixar's been dying while
Elemental managed to grow and make some
money it's by no means the true recovery
that they needed it's by no means the
slingshot bounce back that they actually
needed for the Pixar Department their
live-action remakes are not doing as
strong as they would like to even the
ones that they dump on Disney plus don't
do that well the lady in the tram uh
Pinocchio those don't do that well even
when they try pushing it there uh every
bit of like the actual main Brands when
it comes to them yeah it's it's like
I don't know they got The Simpsons on
there they got these other things but I
don't really open my Disney Plus app
personally and and I'd be more Curious
like you have a family like you do you
not show do you show them I don't know
if they're at the age at where you're
like showing them cartoons or whatever
but
I think there's like other little
there's other kids shows that I'm sure
that are on there that are worth
watching like for the family
but in terms of like acquiring new
because because the thing with the
streaming Wars it's always about it's
like it's like YouTube uh but but a lot
more money writing on it when it comes
to streaming it's about acquiring more
subscribers acquiring more subscribers
get more people to sign up you gotta
return you got need retention and you
need to get new ones every single year
you gotta keep playing that acquiring
game and if these new shows are not
popping off or becoming the Talk of the
Town you're not going to be able to
increase those numbers and at the end of
the day it's all dying but I think like
the one
I don't know how much weight there
actually is to me saying this it doesn't
seem likely
you know we we talk about the
oversaturation especially if we just
like isolate the Marvel Brand
specifically of oversaturation of Marvel
and if they play it smart they can
actually really spread this out and they
could put more emphasis on the project
and take a little bit more time to
ensuring the project is good with the
delays make sure the project is worthy
to have a conversation around that could
be positive
hopefully so you don't get like another
secret Invasion situation or uh you know
what's happened with their movies but
specifically the shows which have often
kind of just been passable lately
even though I love like Miss Marvel as
well
specifically I'm talking about like what
happened with secret Invasion so if with
the delays the one positive I can see is
that okay if we get some breather from
Marvel oh Marvel's coming back let's put
a lot of emphasis on
ironheart and see if we can generate a
lot of hype for that and really make
this more qualitative in the
post-production process let's let's put
a lot of quality into that then you get
another breather
as opposed to we got
six Disney Plus shows this year or
something like that where it feels like
there's more quantity they can basically
redirect their focus into making it more
qualitative that's the one main positive
I can see where they can actually build
more of a spotlight per project
because like with Echo coming out this
year with the amount that was originally
coming out
you're like who gives a about Echo
we got this this and this I don't give a
about Echo now if you got space and
as well you've got to look forward to is
this one thing then maybe you can
actually put more of an emphasis on it
to
increase anticipation I don't know how
likely that is but it's at least worth a
shot if you're going to be making the
properties that's the one real positive
I can see on it yeah it's a bit of a
weird time personally uh like my YouTube
channel I always used to just hammer out
a video every day didn't matter if I
really had a topic just make sure you
get a video out to hit the algorithm and
I've realized over time that it's
actually better to take breaks and do
more quality videos not like this
podcast or anything but for example like
more in-depth breakdowns and things that
really look into stuff rather than just
hammering out a video for the sake of it
and I hope they go with that idea of
making the best product possible and
just putting their all into it rather
than being like oh this is just another
thing on the the factory line that we're
chugging out yeah and but streaming is
becoming quite dangerous financially and
so Forbes have actually put out a report
discussing how the movie industry and
goal is lost roughly about 40 billion
dollars and putting their all into
streaming now obviously when I was
streaming you know some a company like
Disney's 13 billion in the whole from
Disney plus but on top of this they've
also worked out things like M capping
physical media releases multiple
releases multiple formats and just
everywhere that they used to distribute
a movie those networks are almost gone
now
um and it's really had an effect to the
point now I think it was five years they
said they've lost about 40 billion
dollars from doing this strategy and
just putting it all into streaming now
for example the way that things used to
work back in the day you you'd show a
movie in a theater for a couple of
months not like how they do now where
it's like they're three weeks and then
on digital and but it'd be there for a
couple of months people will go out and
see it and then it would be roughly
about a year later when you'd get the
the physical media release the VHS or
the DVD now what would then happen is
that it would move to be sold to cable
networks TV shows and this could be
something that could do worldwide for
example in the UK it was roughly
normally about two years after a movie
came out they do a big world premiere
well not World premiere because it's in
the UK but a premiere on the home TV
premiere of a certain film
um and they would show and they'd make a
big deal out of it and the studio
obviously made money from selling it to
the network the network could put ads in
the middle of it was such a big thing
don't really have that anymore because
of streaming
um now what they do is
they put it in the cinema
then they sell in digital a couple of
weeks later it's probably on streaming
and alongside that you Disney plus do it
really wear the the Disney plus release
comes before the physical media release
which I've always found weird but I'm a
physical media collector so I buy it
um I don't actually buy digital
because I know it's going to be on
streaming soon
and if I'm not that hyped about going to
see a movie I don't go see it because I
know it's going to be on digital soon so
there's this weird thing and I I feel
like a lot of people have adapted this
mentality and was kind of pushing the
pandemic where
you know if you miss a movie it's going
to be on streaming soon
um and obviously they built in their
their whole money service now is putting
everything on streaming so they've lost
the revenue from the physical media
sales digital sales don't perform as
well now because stuff's going to be on
streaming very soon and things like you
know Network TV cable TV everything like
that it's not the big money maker that
it used to be because they're pushing it
all under streaming so they've actually
cut off these revenue streams to to
build up these platforms that have in
turn lost the money
um because of how much everything costs
but also you know lost the money from
the way that
um that they've they've would make stuff
on the back end like you used to be able
to have a movie that was a flop but if
it did well on physical media it made
back a lot of money and that's that's
completely gone now because it doesn't
really make money when it's when it's on
streaming and I I feel like that they're
starting to regret it now which is
they've realized their mistake and this
is why we've seen things like one
division Loki the Mandalorian they're
getting 4K steelbook releases because
Disney realized like oh crap we're
leaving money on the table here and and
to do it this late when it's those shows
have been out for years it just reeks to
me that they've they realize it's been
such a massive mistake to do that in the
first place and cut off that big Revenue
stream that they had where people would
buy stuff just to collect it and I I
feel like they they followed the Spotify
model and thought that they could apply
to films where you know you have a
subscription service and you can
basically listen or play play whatever
move your TV show you want that's on
that
streaming service now the difference is
a song a song doesn't cost 250 million
dollars to make you just get a
microphone go into a recording studio
you might not even go into a recording
studio you can just do it at home and
yeah you've uh you've made yourself a
song there
whereas a movie costs a lot more
um it's something Christopher Nolan's
talked about as well physical media and
I I feel like the the streaming stuff
kind of cheapens it almost where it I
feel like you don't actually own it
until you have it on physical media I
feel like if it's on a streaming
platform you don't really
it's not yours you know what I mean and
I feel like they've just massively shut
themselves in the foot and these figures
kind of kind of prove it as well
I mean you covered it all man like yeah
it's all
it's it seems like they didn't really
factor in
the long-term strategy of it all
Netflix was such a game changer Netflix
was a game changer for a lot of things
remember Netflix started off with
physical media right uh yeah which we
had to get the DVDs you didn't have to
go to a video store anymore I have to go
to Redbox you just have it mailed it and
stuff I still have a DVD I never
returned I wonder how much I've
how much it's affected my credit they
they said
they said you can keep it they put out a
statement at the end of the week
genuinely yeah they genuinely put a
statements
we haven't got the storage anymore
uh they start off with that so that in
and of itself was a game changer and
then they had the this then they created
the streaming service
and you know now they have like over 200
million worldwide subscribers for it
change the game forever
and that took a lot of build and a lot
of innovation and then there's a lot of
people who just wanted to play copy and
catch up
and there's this thing called uh that I
learned about a long time they called
like the law of the lid
basically that
if you're like it if let's say Paul
you're like at a level nine and I'm at a
level six so if I'm constantly trying to
like copy you or follow you I'm never
going to be able to match you because I
you you've created the lid so I got to
create something different I got to
create something more Innovative to
surpass
and Netflix has created this like top
tier lid that you can't surpass and
everyone's just trying to copy and
follow and everyone just kind of shot
themselves in the foot due to this and
and a lot of people also forget that
Netflix took a very long time to become
profitable they took extremely long time
it says it took like I think the people
originally it was like four years then
with the streaming service and the
amount of money they put into it it took
another long gestated amount of time to
finally become profitable and then to
see what's happening here with the
streaming services it also makes sense
with everything that's been going on
with the strikes when you look back on
that with the amount of you know
cracking the whip on the Riders and then
and the actors especially the writers
and not paying them enough and the whole
production cruise and whatnot the amount
of work that they asked them to do
without true fair compensation and then
why there's also a lot of fraught
tension there's a lot of panic happening
and why they refuse to release their
numbers because a lot of this is not
going to look good in the end it's kind
of crazy to see just how much money has
been lost because when you think about
like 40 billion dollars and just how
much money has been spent on this
it doesn't really feel if you'd like to
scroll through any of these streaming
services and all and the original
content produced on them most of them
you've either never watched or never
heard of you know vast majority of them
and it's really sad to see what's become
of it and it's also sad to see now how
there's didn't Disney Just Produce
something was it Disney The Spiderwick
chronic is that what I'm thinking of the
spider one yeah yeah something
that they it wasn't just a pilot they
actually shot it they actually shot the
whole thing
and now they're not even going to
release it because they're like it just
it wouldn't make sense we would just
lose money on it it's insane that that's
almost unheard of to shoot a whole thing
to shoot a pilot and not air it that
makes sense but to shoot a whole to
shoot a series and not air it it's the
the amount of
work that the that these that the actors
creators are all putting into this and
then not feel like they're getting paid
fairly and then the amount of money
that's being wasted too
a lot of it just seems like really poor
strategy and a desperate attempt to
catch up with Netflix and and I've and
none of them have really they can't pass
Netflix man Netflix is still King I
still might it's Netflix is still the
number one streaming service I
personally use I still use them way more
than all the other ones
yeah and it it seems like they're almost
kind of retroactively going like they
want to go back to the old models
because they're doing ad tier stuff now
and they're they're trying to get stuff
to the point where ADS are integrated
into it again annoying and kind of
annoying yeah
and going back to Ahsoka those viewing
figures I actually wonder if that's
gonna damage that add to your stuff
because you know it is kind of taking it
to that whole network TV thing where a
show would get canceled if if it did
that badly because the ads just wouldn't
you know it'd be so difficult to sell to
advertisers and I wonder if you know if
the viewing figures on stuff's crap if
they're gonna find it difficult to set
sell to advertisers again on their ad TS
stuff
um it's such a weird thing that they're
doing it
I mean I I got my bill through for
Netflix the other week and it was over
20 pounds because we've added another
household to it now and it's just
getting crazy
um I'm really just getting to the point
where I wish the streaming wars were
over and it will it will probably get to
a point where everything just kind of
Netflix buys everything or Disney buys
everything on Apple buys everything and
it goes into one platform but
I think what um I think what Prime Video
has done is really smart
because you know I'm having Amazon Prime
Loops you into having Prime video I
think that's hey that was that was a
smart move I believe they're the second
one behind like they're really close to
Netflix I believe that the second one
behind them but they're all also their
video they have they have like several
sections right they have stuff where you
could watch free without ads they have
some live TV on there as well they got
like a good amount of options
and there are also their video on demand
is pretty accurate like you're right
buying on digital is not as lucrative as
they probably hoped especially because
you know there was a time where we would
wait a very long time before something
could actually come out on on physics
like growing up for some reason my mind
always goes to Toy Story 2 of waiting
like a whole year after watching it in
the theaters and then it finally games
they used to wait a long ass time now
gets just released on video on
demand while it's still in the theaters
you know it happens with so many movies
now
um
and you know what they they do something
that because because there's a lot of
movies that obviously I do like the
reaction commentaries for uh and and I I
always have the option to either rent it
or buy it on video on demand
and their rental price is always 19.99
but their purchase price is
24.99 so I'm always and there's a lot of
people I'm fortunate enough for the five
dollar difference is not a big enough
deal to me where I I can afford that
five dollars some people it's it's a
make or break where they're like no I I
want to keep that five dollars which I
understand but for there's a lot of
people out there where it's like well I
might not be able to finish it and I
don't want to confine myself to a
48-hour window and it's just five
dollars more I might as well just buy it
you know so it's actually like a clever
persuasive way to get you to buy the
movie when it's because it's kind of
ridiculous that will because it just
makes you go I might as well just buy
this one it's only it's twenty dollars
to rent to 25 to actually own the thing
forever you know but I also have that
feeling that you're talking about though
too of of of of not actually really
owning it because I think to myself what
if I don't have my Prime account anymore
what if for some reason Amazon Prime
just shut down I wouldn't own any of the
countless movies that I now own because
I chose to buy it instead of rented now
so I actually I do agree with that
feeling that you're talking about the
difference between owning physical media
um versus buying something on digital in
fact I actually feel that way with video
games as well like uh you know when it
comes to buying a lot of people just
download a video game and I prefer to
buy the physical media on top of that
too
that's the same I got pinned by iTunes
back in the day really badly because
when I was a student I got my new iPod
and uh all the songs were like 79p and I
say oh just buy another song I'll just
buy another song I spent like 300 pound
in the first month which when I was a
student that was like my life savings
and then a couple of years later I just
ended up getting rid of it and losing
all my purchases and then since then
I've just been like Nat by by everything
physical because it's not even really
that much of a price difference like I
used to trade in a lot of my games as
well
um any I'd even sell them on eBay so I'd
buy a game play through it if if I loved
it I'd keep it if I thought it was okay
or bad I'd sell it on eBay and I'll at
least get some money back from it but
I'm seeing these digital
costs for games are the same price as it
would be just buy physical copy and I
just yeah you know there's no trading or
selling it so if you don't like it you
kind of stuck with it and which I don't
really get
but yeah that's uh that's my thoughts on
it it's a any thoughts that you have
Greg for always any other topics you
want to cover I know we've got a lot but
I'm looking at the time there the
viewers have been with us for an hour
and 20 minutes at a
don't know if I want to put them through
another 20 minutes of us rambling
I'm good for I'm good for it today I
feel like this one's fine did it go fine
I thought we had some good points of
scad throughout the complete nonsense as
per usual but yeah thanks guys for
sticking with us
thank you
I feel like there's some executive out
there somewhere listening and jotting
stuff down like oh crap don't don't lose
40 billion on streaming gotta take that
into the office and be like this is to
go on the to-do list
um yeah but I do kind of feel like stuff
obviously stuff evolves and changes over
time like I never actually thought we
would get physical media releases of One
Division stuff I did originally when the
shows first came out I thought oh
there's no way they don't release this
physically because people will buy it
and also keep the Disney Plus
subscription but I think they thought
that people would buy it and then cancel
their subscription which is like now
mate you don't understand how collectors
work they will keep that going in the
background and
spend sixty dollars on a steel book as
well especially um so yeah yeah
especially for the fandom yeah
oh mate the amount of times I've bought
the MCU at this point is absolutely
ridiculous because I bought a Blu-ray
sold it to get the 4ks and then they
released all the IMAX versions on Disney
Plus or sold all them and then I thought
I'm gonna buy them again but this time I
was into steelbook collecting so I
bought them all the steel books which is
like some of those older movies the
price on the the steel books if you
don't get a steel book when it first
releases then you're gonna get shafted
on the price I'll try and buy the into
the spider-verse steel book every week
at least once a week and it's always 120
or something I just think it's too much
it's too it's though it's a one of my
collection that I don't own but I'm
still like it's too much it's too much
um so yeah
it seems like they're shifting back to
it when they start selling those Disney
Plus shows as physical releases maybe
they've realized you know maybe the
accountants come in and said look how
much money you've lost time to go back
to the old ways
um but yeah we'll see and obviously this
actually means more money for Strikers
and the actors and residuals and stuff
because that was where a lot of the
money used to come from whereas when
it's on streaming they can kind of hide
the numbers but that's a topic for
another day uh we'll board you enough
guys thanks again for supporting us and
if you want to check out our merch the
links below you can go over to Greg's
Channel at the real rejects watch his
reactions he's going through one piece
at the moment just started it out so
you're not gonna miss out much you'll be
able to catch up very quickly and just
see the guy's thoughts on it Greg is
there anything you want to say final
final words final words this time no no
I mean uh thank you guys for uh it's
it's been a journey being here and uh
thank you Paul for
having me be here with you buddy I
it's interesting you know it sounds so
sad it's it there's just a little I'm
still I'm still I'm still recovering a
little bit uh no I mean it's not one
comment from like three weeks ago
there's always like the same two people
I'll see a lot of positivity we'll get
fan art and I'll see the safe two people
and I'll be like that son of a
just ruined my boo it's the way you know
how my my mentality works
um yeah
I but I no I appreciate those who are
are uh who have been very welcoming as
I've been or it's you know it's like
it's kind of an it's been an interesting
Journey for me because
you know like I'm so used to just being
on my channel right and then oftentimes
would be like
oh I might guest on someone's Channel my
guest on someone's Channel and this is
the first time in the entire time I've
been doing this from like I'm starting
up something new
on someone else's audience you know and
so it's it's different it's it's been a
journey of like another reevaluation of
just learning to be myself again because
I get in my own head about stuff so as
I've been going through the process of
just getting comfortable with my myself
is that that's where it starts with it's
just getting self-comfortable and so I
appreciate everyone who's who's been
here with me and I've been enjoying my
time here I like it here it's different
than what I do on my channel so I'm
really enjoying my time here so thank
you guys we haven't missed a week yet
and uh we hope you guys are back next
week if you want to listen to us on the
go Spotify Amazon Apple music podcasts
whatever it's across the spoilerverse
remember
see you next time